Hi everybody,
and welcome back to my channel.
Today I really wanted to talk about something.
I've been seeing it a lot on the internet
and I want to address it.
And that is
a lot of women are
putting a big emphasis on their future husband
making a certain amount of money
and having particular physical characteristics.
And let's talk about that.
So I'm sure you guys have heard of it
and seen these street interviews of these women
saying that they want a six pack,
six foot tall,
six figure man,
or saying particular numbers and things like that.
And if you are wanting to attract a masculine man,
a man who wants to provide for his future wife,
I would restrain yourself from using any
vocabulary that is like that.
That's not gonna get you a provider, man.
That's not gonna get you a man that looks anything
or acts anything like that.
That is gonna push men away from you.
A feminine woman won't say these things.
She could, however, say,
I would like to be with a provider.
But you don't need to list any salary
amount or anything like that.
To be honest,
I didn't even know the money my husband made
until later in our dating life
because it didn't matter.
What matters is his character.
And if he can show you that,
he will be a provider.
And he will show you that very early on.